de marc urbain proulx est avec nous ce
soir bonsoir marque urbains pau bonsoir
étudions l'impact de la coved 19 pour le
saguenay-lac-saint-jean comment ça se
passe bah ça se passe ça se passe un peu
comme dans le reste du québec
mais disons qu'ici on est un peu moins
affecté que que qu'ailleurs au québec au
canada et ailleurs dans le monde
pourquoi parce que le taux de
contamination est moins élevé comme dans
plusieurs autres régions qu'elle
saguenay lac saint jean et parce
qu'aussi que beaucoup d'entreprises
industrielles ont réussi à ne pas fermer
les ports alors autour de 70 à 75 80 %
des entreprises industrielles ont réussi
à continuer de de produire bien
souligner autour des exemples comme rio
tinto ou comme les tabatières ou comme
do d'entreprises industrielles de même
des services spécialisés aussi qu'il
travaille avec le virtuel du travail à
distance et qui ont continué
comptabilité le droit et fera les
continue quand même de faire fonctionner
leur entreprise grâce au travail à
distance
alors françois legault va présenter un
plan national de réouverture la semaine
prochaine est ce que vous pensez qu'il
devrait y avoir des plans régionaux de
relance de réouverture de l'économie
bien oui je crois ou ai tout à fait même
je crois que je crois qu'on devrait se
baser sur les plans locaux que nous
avons actuellement à région les plans
des à l'échelle des mrc notamment on a
des outils on a des aménagistes des
schémas d'aménagement des plans de
développement
le des plans sectoriels aussi qui touche
l'emploi le touriste ecce terra les
régions seulement les régions
périphériques mais on peut tout le
québec tous les territoires au québec à
la base avec les municipalités et puis
au dessus des municipalités
l'été les municipalités régionales de
comté sont équipés pour planifier
beaucoup de planificateur dans
différents secteurs d'activité je pense
que le plan de relance de monsieur
legault devrait utiliser ces plans l'eau
pour remonter pour nourrir en réalité le
plan de relance du québec et est ce
qu'on devrait rouvrir plus rapidement
les régions compte tenu que la coved 19
frappé quand même pas mal plus fort
à montréal en montérégie à laval est ce
qu'on devrait les régions comme le
bas-saint-laurent le
saguenay-lac-saint-jean ouvrir plus
rapidement bien et un des boss sur cela
évidemment il ya des gens qui se
prononce pour ou contre -
personnellement je pense que oui où on
devrait ouvrir les régions
progressivement bien sûr en utilisant en
ayant différentes mesures pour protéger
le plus possible pour qu'il y ait trop
de contamination mais on devrait rouvrir
les régions vous avez parlé du tourisme
à tout à l'heure le touriste c'est plus
des dix corps parce que évidemment il ya
un effet de masse dans les lits
touristiques liés au restaurant il ya eu
au tel y'a des rassemblements et cetera
mais je pense qu'avec des bonnes mesures
de protection pour réguler ce secteur en
particulier
je pense que oui les régions devraient
ouverte l'été prochain pour pour le pour
le tourisme du poumon de tissu
économique
oui bah ça fait partie du tissu
c'est peut-être pas un moteur heymans
mais ce moteur important légion le
touriste évidemment avec des
spécificités la base contenant assez a
ses particularités les gens y vont pour
l'exotisme d'ailleurs dans charlevoix
c'est pour d'autres raisons
mais les régions du québec offrent une
variété de produits et de services
touristiques qui quand on parle d'achat
local parce que monsieur legault on
parle beaucoup quand on parle d'achat
local bien c'est d'abord ce serait
d'abord visité le québec qui est on le
fait déjà depuis beaucoup de gens le
font mais je pense qu'il faut faire
encore davantage nous avons deux
magnifiques régions à visiter
alors cette année comme montréal et plus
plus en difficulté ça va être difficile
de réouvrir montréal au tourisme ont
dérobé m
à mon avis serait plus difficile dans ce
sera une belle année pour que les les
gens du grand montréal avait visité les
régions du québec et se rend compte des
beautés puis date tous les services
qu'on offre en région est ce qu'on doit
miser donc cette saison complexe qu'on
va vivre sur l'achat local justement
principalement là dessus bien coûter oui
le panier bleus je pense que c'est une
bonne idée
beaucoup de produits du terroir seront
développés au cours des dernières années
un peu partout au québec mais notamment
région parle des bières ou des fromages
des choses je pense que le panier bleus
va stimuler ce genre de deux de
production locale je pense que les
québécois vont se tourner vers des
achats de vêtements bien sûr de
chaussures tout ce qu'on plus fabriqué
au québec mais notamment les produits du
terroir mais je pense qu'on peut aller
encore plus loin avec ce que je vous
parlais tout à l'heure c'est à dire
mobiliser des collectivités locales et
régionales pour qu'ils collaborent de
plein fouet y collaborent des gens mais
il ya un espèce d'attentisme
depuis sept ou huit ans au québec à
l'échelle d'aider des municipalités des
ministres était régionale de comté on
atteint 1 on atteint alors je pense que
c'est tentant tisme pourrait être trouvé
solution avec le plan de relance de
monsieur legault en ayant un incitatif
pour permettre aux localités d'exprimer
ce qu'ils veulent dans leur région
qu'est ce que voulait dire marc
incitatif un incitatif pour que les gens
s'assoient ensemble c'est à dire qu'on a
eu on a beaucoup de ressources en région
beaucoup de retard beaucoup de personnes
qualifiées
mon est dispersée chacun dans nos
d'anodin aux organistes dans nos
secteurs d'activité et c'est rare qu'on
peut s'asseoir ensemble pour avoir une
vision globale de nos territoires en
charlevoix par exemple ou dans le bas
saint laurent où la basse-côte-nord
s'asseoir ensemble et c'est de voir
ensemble avec nos stratégies
sectorielles nos stratégies locales
déçu de voir quelle stratégie on peut
avoir pour le territoire en question que
ce soit que ce soit saguenay où que ce
soit à chibougamau
où que ce soit un jeu de paume dans la
vallée du richelieu musulmans les
régions périphériques qui doit faire cet
exercice de vision globale plus assez de
voir ensemble qu'est ce qu'on peut
qu'est ce qu'on a comme vocation pour
notre territoire
s'asseoir ensemble virtuellement d'abord
marc urbains pau merci beaucoup plaisir